but Nancy Pelosi is just getting started
in the one hunt in the 116 Congress she
will continue to fight hard for the
people Nancy Pelosi will fight to lower
health care costs strengthen the
Affordable Care Act protect people with
pre-existing conditions increase pay for
everyday Americans and act the real
infrastructure plan clean up corruption
defend the dreamers fix the Voting
Rights Act and in the era of voter
suppression once and for all Nancy
Pelosi
Nancy Pelosi will fight for a country
that provides for the poor works for
working families make sense for the
middle class stands up for senior
citizens innovates in the inner city and
strengthens suburban communities Nancy
Pelosi is a woman of faith a loving wife
a mother of five a grandmother of nine a
sophisticated strategist a legendary
legislator a voice for the voiceless a
defender of the disenfranchised a
powerful profound prophetic principle
public servant and that's why we stand
squarely behind her today let me be
clear House Democrats are down with NDP
Nancy D'Allesandro Pelosi the once and
future Speaker of the United States
House of Representatives are proudly
placed her name in nomination may God
bless her may God bless the United
States of America
[Applause]